yes one of hungary's superstars richard
report
let me say
you've didn't start off great in this
event but you must be feeling really
good where you are right now uh yeah
sure i mean uh yeah
today i was also very lucky because my
first game i was
kind of repeating what i did against
lanier basically like getting horrible
evolution out of the opening but um yeah
this time i got really lucky and you
know i even got to be able to win
and after that i think i kind of played
okay so um yeah of course have to read
the score could you imagine you'd have
gotten to this position after the
beginning i mean you're right there in
the thick of it i think you're tied for
second place right now
oh yeah you know i mean i was 50 right
after the first day so it's not like
unimaginable to uh i don't know score
two wins but sure uh you know i had my
chances even yesterday i didn't convert
a single one so um
yeah i'm very happy with today yeah
it's time for the blitz what kind of
blitz player are you
that's a very good question i guess we
are going to see that tomorrow yeah
you are chasing downhill nakamura this
would be quite a challenge you didn't
get to play the first event in bucharest
uh still thinking about competing for
the tour
uh you know
not really right i mean i have one
tournament basically behind and also
perry's i think i made
around fifth place which is you know not
too great right um
we'll see but uh hopefully just you know
one day at the time yeah one day at a
time indeed good luck in the blitz
looking forward to see you play your
best
richard uh first of all uh nice nice
nice uh result uh good luck in the blitz
but uh tell us about your fashion
you're sporting a very intriguing shirt
tell us the
tell us a bit about the shirt
but the shirt no i actually had this
shirt for some time but i just generally
like to you know
pay attention to what i wear i like to
you know
wear sometimes a little bit unusual
stuff yeah yes as long as it's nice why
not right looks great yep looks great on
camera
thank you good luck in the blitz thanks